Adam Sandler may have made Millions
playing lovable goofballs but his
personal life has been marked by sadness
and tragedy from being publicly mocked
by his former bosses to losing his
closest friend the Billy Madison star
knows what it's like to be at his lowest
Adam Sandler landed a spot on Saturday
Night Live after proving himself as a
writer and appearing in a few movies and
television shows his tenure on the
sketch comedy series coincided with one
of the show's most beloved eras much to
the dismay of his fans however s and
Chris Farley left SNL after the 1994 to
95 season at the time audience were left
thinking that the two stars had quit but
in recent years Sandler has exposed the
truth of his Exodus from The Late Night
series drawing an appearance on the
Howard Stern Show Sandler admitted the
NBC head dude I know he didn't like our
gang me and Farley the actor also
recalled how his manager let him down
easy about being fired Sandler revealed
to stern at the time I was hurt because
I was I didn't know what else I was
going to do thankfully Sandler became a
box office sensation and holds no
grudges he even returned to host SNL in
2019 where he made light of being fired
with a musical monologue fans may look
back funly on Adam Sandler's 5-year run
on Saturday Night Live but the actor
holds some deep regrets about his tenure
on the show in an interview with AARP
Sandler reminisced about his SNL days
and expressed disappointment with much
of his early conduct he told the outlet
I used to go nuts had a quick temper
quick reactions I made a lot of dumb
mistakes and said a lot of stupid things
looking back on relationships I could be
an ass I was selfish I was competitive
with other comedians the actor also
admitted that his aggressive Pursuit Of
Fame left him unable to acknowledge the
talent of his peers he added I was
hungry I didn't always see clearly then
I wanted to be a big comedian like Eddie
Murphy like Rodney Dangerfield
thankfully Sandler has matured a lot
since his SNL days and is no longer as
competitive as he once was he told a I
appreciate other people's talents now
rather than competing I'll watch
somebody and say man they're great I
never would have thought of that joke or
that approach even though it isn't his
first movie 1995's Billy Madison is
often credited as launching Adam
Sandler's huge film career stop looking
at me Swan the movie is about a Manchild
forc to complete several grade school
classes in order to secure his father's
estate it was also the first film
Sandler coose to the screenwriting
partner Tim Hurley Billy Madison is
considered a classic today but at the
time of its release critics were not on
board with Sandler's immature Antics and
obnoxious energy notably Roger eert used
the opportunity to focus on the actor's
screen presentence comparing him to
fingernails on a Blackboard sadly
Sandler was Ill prepared for the barrage
of negative comments telling deadline in
2022 when Billy Madison came out me and
my friend who wrote it read the first
review and we were like oh my god what
happened they they hate us and then we
were like it must have been this paper
but then 90% of the papers are going
this is garbage I did stop reading them
after that since then Sandler has been
pretty hostile towards critics and the
media in general Adam Sandler has
developed a notorious reputation for
avoiding interviews with the media and
for good reason the comedian can
pinpoint a couple of events early in his
career when he was misquoted which
resulted in his distrust for journalists
he told the Harvard Crimson in 2000 one
time I was in a room with a person who
kept going on and on about how much he
loved the movie that night I see him on
TV saying this movie is useless and I'm
like dude that's a guy who was nice to
me another example of how the meteor has
done s Wrong came up during a 2023
interview with the Washington Post in
the interview Sandler record a moment in
1995 when he was quoted in TV Guide for
saying the writing on SNL was bad St
recall to the post I go I never said
that I never would say that I called the
writer I said why did you say I said
that and he kind of didn't want to talk
to me I should have taped the
conversation since then the actor has
spent most of his career avoiding
interviews and critics however he
admitted to AARP that he's still hurt by
negative reviews saying mostly because I
invite all these amazing people I care
about to make movies with me and I wish
they didn't have to read about whatever
we've made at the height of his film
career in 1999 stess started Happy
Madison Productions from there he struck
a long-term deal with Sony Pictures
which saw him starring 24 films for the
company however things didn't end so
well between Sandler and Sony in 2014
Sandler signed a multi-picture deal with
Netflix which essentially put an end to
his relationship with Sony with a
boatload of money coming his way from
the streaming service the maneuver
seemed like a natural transition however
news soon came to light that there was
far more going on behind the scenes
between Sandler and his former
distributor after malicious hackers
raided Sony pictures in 2014 emails
featuring Sandler's name surfaced in
discussions between Sony's heads the
comedic Powerhouse was described as a
self-important jerk whose best days were
behind him the actor has never publicly
addressed his falling out with Sony or
the emails but after a long-standing and
fruitful relationship that one had to
hurt Adam Sandler would be the first
person to admit that he is not perfect
and throughout his career the actor has
described many of the personal
challenges that he has had to overcome
during an interview at the Harvard
Crimson in 200 the comedian admitted
that he has an anger problem saying in
real life I do have a bit of that
problem but over the years I've been
getting better I think Sandler also said
he relates to the loser characters he
often depicts on screen he admitted on
the little gold men podcast I just have
a natural part of my brain that feels
like I don't belong here this feeling
uncomfortable and loser stuff I've been
doing for years it's in me in recent
years Sandler has been proactive in
treating his mental health telling AARP
I talk to a shrink sometimes he's given
me a plan sometimes just holding in a
sentence taking a beat for a minute
before saying something stupid when I do
that I realize it wasn't that important
to say it in the first place with Fame
comes consequence for Adam Sandler that
means he spends a lot of time dealing
with legal disputes for instance
Sandler's 2008 film You Don't Mess with
the Zohan landed the actor in hot water
after cartoonist Robert cabel claimed
that the lead character was plagiarized
the film which is an about an Israeli
counterterrorist Commando turn
hairdresser did share many similarities
with cabel's cartoon James blonde in
cabel's cartoon the lead character is a
Navy Seals trained hair stylist who
fights crime in 2013 Sandler and Company
was sued Again by a carpenter who lost
his finger while building sets for
That's My Boy the complaint sought $1
million for gross negligence after
Sandler's production company failed to
provide the proper safety equipment
required for the job but Sandler's most
drawn out case involved a professional
nanny named Dean McDonald who he hired
to care for his children children
McDonald originally settled a dispute
with Sandler out of court the suit
involved undisclosed employment claims
however after breaching a clause in the
settlement McDonald was ordered to repay
the actor
$80,000 since he's no longer a young
performer Sandler has felt the signs of
aging the actor started getting
concerned about his physical health
while filming back-to-back features
murder mystery 2 and his upcoming movie
Spaceman he told variety I was hanging
in a harness all the time I kept saying
something going on with my hip man I was
like yeah I definitely got to x-ray that
thing and we were in trouble the actor
underwent hip surgery in September 2022
and was understandably in a lot of Agony
for some time after my hip surgery was
painful Sandler also admitted that the
surgery made him feel old however when
asked about how he felt after surgery
the actor joked to page six I screamed a
lot then calmed down and ate some food
it has become somewhat of a tradition
for Adam Sandler to cast his friends in
his Productions after after all
grown-ups and its sequel were
essentially conceptualized as an
opportunity to spend more time with his
buddies so there is no doubt that
camaraderie is a core value to Sandler
unfortunately with over 70 film credits
to his name the actor has had to say
goodbye to many co-stars throughout the
years some of the notable friends of
Sandler who have passed away include Bob
Barker and Cloris leechman there are a
couple of deaths that hit Sandler harder
than others nor McDonald who shared the
stage with Sandler on SNL and had his
first movie credit on Billy Madison
passed away in 2021 after Norm's passing
a heartbroken Sandler shed on X formerly
known as Twitter every one of us loved
Norm some of the hardest laughs of my
life with this man most Fearless funny
original guy we knew an incredible dad a
great friend a legend still the most
heartbreaking loss for Sandler was the
timely passing of Chris Farley in 1997
after spending time on SNL together
Farley was one of Sandler's closest
Confidant ravioli holy can holy Sandler
still misses his former co-star and
memorialized him with a 4-minute tribute
song drawing his hosting appearance on
SNL in 2019 there was something just
something very uh powerful that night
and I felt felt great talking about
Chris there is one thing that Adam
Sandler values Above All Else family the
actor gives much of the credit for his
success to the endless support he
received growing up while accepting the
2023 Mark Twain Prize for American humor
the comedian said there was one thing
that led him to the night I come from a
great family tragically Adam Sandler was
hit with a significant loss in 2003 when
his father Stanley passed away the actor
has held much respect for his father
throughout his career even using him as
inspiration for his character in 2022
hustle he said to ET Canada I was just
basically doing my dad when he used to
coach my teams growing up his kind of
demeanor it'd push you but then it'd
also say like all right I see my kids
about to snap let me pull back a little
bit understandably the former SNL star
was devastated by the loss of his father
especially after watching his health
decline Sandler told parade I went
through stuff with my dad before he died
I saw firsthand what goes on with people
who are incredibly sick the actor still
holds a special place in his heart for
Stanley Sandler in a 2020 Facebook post
he wrote my dad the greatest man I ever
knew love you so Dad I know I was a
mistake but I know you had a good time
thanks for having me and miss you every
day